is soy not safe for cancer even if it's organic. So first point is that done
most soy that this person obviously probably recognizes most soy that's
grown and sold in United States is GMO soy which is not good for anybody. So if it
is organic is soy okay. Okay so soy is going to be an endocrine disruptor it's
gonna have estrogen properties and it can be a problem for everyone even if
person doesn't have cancer. So certainly if you have cancer it could be a worst
problem and most importantly it could be a bad problem for those with cancer that
is a hormone driven. So if you have an estrogen driven or progesterone driven
cancer then soy I would say is completely out of the question whether it's
organic or not it doesn't make any difference. If you don't have cancer is soy
okay if it's organic. I would still say probably not we're exposed to so many
Zedo estrogen that's estrogen said estrogen like products from our
environment that that throw off our hormone balance that soy should be generally
unknown all for everybody whether it's organic or not. Is soy in different
products about that there's different soy isoclaminoids in different products as
that abandoned well not always so if a person is going through menopause and
they're trying to balance they're having horrible symptoms and they're trying to
balance their estrogen soy isoclaminoids can be an extremely beneficial piece to
that. So I'm not against using it wisely as a medicinal approach to Zedo. There's
prognosis there's research that gennist can be fantastic for ovarian cancer and
other hormone driven cancers and then lastly I'll say about soy is that that
all soy is equal as far as if it's fermented soy or not. So a fermented soy which
would be in some traditional Japanese cuisine but a fermented soy acts
completely different then soy does the non fermented soy so fermented soy is
actually a treatment approach for different cancers that are estrogen driven
because it's been found in different studies that fermented soy actually
dislodges bad estrogens as they attach to the estrogen beta receptor of cancer
cells and that's a big problem that with an estrogen driven cancers. So fermented
soy is completely different than non fermented soy and there's only a couple
products on the market that actually have fermented soy so you would know what
you're getting. However, if you're eating traditional Japanese cuisine with
fermented soy that can actually be protective of cancer. If you don't have
cancer and can be beneficial for those who have an estrogen driven cancer and
then lastly like I mentioned soy in a non fermented form it's gonna
traditionally as gonna be in the United States it's gonna be most commonly found
in a GMO form which is not organic and organic so it's still gonna be an
estrogen like some sense it's probably not a good thing for anybody. Now if
it's in a few different things that you're eating some soy and it's probably not
gonna be a problem but a lot of vegans will substitute soy for meat thinking
that it's healthier for them and it's by far not healthier. Much cooler
so that's just you.